Hello
bitches,
if you had the opportunity to go and view any culture from the past,
like if you could be completely invisible and walk around amongst the Romans or
cave people or native Americans before the Europeans came,
what would you choose?
Wow,
that's really hard.
Question.
Yeah.
Um,
I think,
I don't know when the time would be,
but the first time where anything was trying to be colonized,
like changed from being what your regular.
Like the first time I got boat showed up in Polynesia or something like that and
some white people got out,
right?
We're used to being in the fields every day and,
and you know,
this guy hunts and this guy watches after the boys and teaches them and this
one's already more all you know.
And then all of a sudden they come up and they're building like,
you guys.
Well yeah,
you live for colored Cox.
Women are staring at their fucking balls two feet from the ground.
What are these things?
My,
what the fuck is going on?
Jesus Christ.
This guy's got a fucking look at his ears,
jumped off his fucking teeth.
He's got bones in his fucking ear.
Can I get a Bible
lesson?
There was this thing called Noah's Ark.
Sit down.
These fuckers don't pay attention.
Can you fucking round them up?
Calling me and the boys going to need about 40 these fucking things.
Climb trees.
What is your character's name?
I love the guy who needs to come back more often.
This is the conversation,
Joe.
They climb trees.
What do you mean that they fucking.
They don't even don't even with our hands and an agent
out there for 20 minutes.
Eat a Gundam lead.
I run a fuck is going on.
I'm getting eaten by ants.
He's laughing.
I saw a statement was in someone went,
it was a tourist spot,
but I pass the tourist spot and went in the house and there was a statement in
there and I know it just,
it's simple,
but it just blew my mind and it said one person could change the whole world for
a better as long as they don't give a damn.
Who gets that credit and that a fucking day.
And I,
and I thought like if you really don't,
if you just want to sit back,
you just want to see things better and you really can change for the better,
but you don't have to worry about going,
you know,
so and so said that where someone's so set that up so and so did that because
now you're doing it for different reasons.
Yeah.
I never had that before.
I'd never heard that before until like yesterday I saw like I saw that quote
into making that's a problem that I continually have all of us wanting to all of
those ideas.
And that's,
I think part of what's excellent about this medium and particularly the way it's
been executed by you lot,
is that it's,
it's discourse,
you know,
like this kind of things.
Not really,
you know,
like you said,
the fast moving fast cut sound,
bitey,
vidyard,
bombarding of an artillery of mostly erroneous information.
You don't get people here.
People our,
after our talk in examining,
discarding as you said,
who really knows and returning to that point,
it's sort of,
it's sort of encouraging because I've had like,
you know,
like as I like,
I've always felt like an I don't like agree with like a bill o'reilly or Sean
Hannity or those guys.
I've always kind of felt a bit.
I think they were all right if I hung out with a lot.
There's something about bill o'reilly can marginally carve.
Oh,
come on.
Like I think I think he was kind of okay.
You would think you would joke around with them and you guys start laughing
about some things and that's kind of a reassuring thing,
isn't it?
And like it to not be kind of like once you get a like I think that's what's
kind of ugly about both liberalism and neoliberalism is as you can see,
is people just forcing their idea and they've lost touch with.
And I do it all the fucking time.
Yeah.
Let's start with what is it that we're genuinely here for.
And that thing you said of like you can change the world if like,
you know,
no one,
like if you're willing to do,
if no one knowing about it,
that's like,
ah,
the,
that I feel in my gut shows me how much my ego is still involved in the shit I
do.
I'm not a fan of sharks.
I don't like them.
They scare the fuck out of me.
And that's what's keeping me from surfing.
Surfing looks like it's fucking awesome.
I see guys like you on those big waves.
But I don't know about the big waves that that's beyond me.
I believe it.
Even when I was young,
I don't think I ever like this.
This kind of shit does not.
I'm not designed for that.
It's not fun looking.
Nope.
That's not me.
We're looking at,
for people who are listening,
we're looking at an image.
Is that you?
Who's,
who's?
Uh,
that's me.
Well Jesus.
Dude,
tell me about this.
It looks like I'm falling off a building.
It looks like you're falling off several buildings stacked on top of each.
I'll tell you what,
that,
that actual number right there.
I actually felt like I was falling off a building.
It was an,
I was absolutely sure I was eating shit right there.
So.
And you didn't.
Um,
I didn't.
Yeah,
it was a miracle.
I actually fell from the top and landed on my board and made the wave.
And there's a big wave at a,
at a wave off the north coast of Maui called jaws.
Now how high is that wave?
Probably 50 feet on the face.
Maybe,
maybe more.
Maybe 60.
So you're falling off the top of the wave,
like it breaks and you're coming over the lip or the,
what would you call it?
What do you call the edge of the wave came up?
Yeah,
I'm falling from the lip.
But the cool thing is you're doing it with your hands.
You know,
like you're doing it with your bare hands.
Like this wave comes in and you have to read the wave.
You have to time it,
you have to position yourself so you.
So you have to catch it in the steepest part right before it throws over like
that,
because if it throws over your eating shit.
So you know,
you gotta it's just,
it's so precise,
you know,
it'd be able to turn it on a giant wave like that.
Especially like the bigger the wave is the it moves.
So it gets really,
really technical and so,
you know,
a few successfully ride one of those waves.
It's a lot of fun.
I would imagine it gets super addictive when you're in that tube and you're
slicing through it and you see the water.
Oh yeah.
Going over the top of you.
Yeah,
it is,
it is so much fun.
It's like,
um,
it is,
it's such a blast.
It's um,
it's super addicting.
I,
you know,
I've been surfing since I was,
I've been surfing on,
on a surfboard standing up since I was five on my surfboard from my dad and um,
I'm still totally obsessed with it.
It's weird.
There's nothing else in my life like that where I'm absolutely psyched.
Like when the waves are good,
I'm,
I'm like a little kid still.
What is it about it,
dude?
It's like,
it's like hunting.
It really is.
It's like I'm out in nature and no one's bothering me.
I don't need to talk to anybody.
I can go do my own thing.
I can go down the beach no matter how shitty of a day I had,
no matter how much stress,
whatever,
like if my kids getting a bad report card or I had to pay my taxes or whatever
the hell it was,
I can just put on my trunks,
dry down to the beach,
grab my board and I'm good.
And as soon as I hit the water,
I'm fine.
And,
and that's how I am a bowhunting and people who don't bow hunt,
they don't understand that.
They're like,
why the hell would he do that?
Like,
what do you,
what do you find,
you know,
like,
what do you find good about that?
Like being out in the forest for days at a time.
It's the same thing.
Just,
you know,
people who have a porn addiction,
those coasts,
they're like,
I had to stop,
but it was getting crazy.
I couldn't concentrate on anything.
Yeah.
Well,
that's what they're saying.
Michael Jackson had some sort of a sex addiction.
Jesus dark too.
Super Dark,
like midnight.
It's just spooky that that guy was doing that to these kids while he was the
biggest star world.
I mean,
we all know it's true.
What are people still going?
No,
because they don't want to.
They don't want to believe.
Come on.
There's an elementary school near in Hollywood,
uh,
the,
the auditorium for the school as Michael Jackson Auditorium.
Feel free to change that whenever you change.
That's Jamie's version though,
for sure.
It's free.
Oh,
that's so true.
God.
But the sugar amount process,
doesn't matter if it's processed or not.
All right,
let me ask you this.
I got to pick it up.
Put it in the spring.
Bottled water.
I just whip your dick out,
bro.
Guess how much?
Not Small enough for that.
Don't piss all over my floor here.
Yeah,
you can do it in there.
Just just corn hole that we have to go soon anyway because,
uh,
I got to get something somewhere.
I just got a p folks.
Don't put a camera on him because that's rude.
There he goes.
Don't put a camera on them.
We don't lose our that much.
Sugar is in a.
We put the camera nearest Dick or were the
first folks.
That's the first time anybody's peed on the pocket.
Don't take a photo of his dick.
It's blocked by the cup.
Just have you guys taken a photo of your dick,
Bro.
That's a full Kombucha.
Definitely don't drink that.
You're going to piss in the pickles too.
How'd you cut off stream?
For sure.
You dribbling on my car but not fully finished.
Fully,
fully,
fully pinched.
Do.
That's a lot of pig.
That's a lot of fear.
Will be at the comedy store tomorrow night.
Ladies and gentlemen,
go to red.
Great Dot Com and you can buy tickets.
Tell them that you heard him pee on the Joe Rogan experience and you will get
absolutely nothing off your ticket price already.
10 Bucks.
Cock suckers.
It's only 10 bucks folks.
We got pis here if you want it,
we're going to put it on Ebay for poachers were going to poaching Africa.
That's choose to put out some Jupiter.
We're going to stop the poaching with Ari's Piss.